[Music]
here's a Christmas message from Santa
J it was the night before Sid Trek and
here we are live sci-fi and silliness
Sundays at
5 Harris is here with all that hair the
rest of us thinking that's bloody unfair
our young American will be a big star
when he stars in the remake of Dude
where's my
car stormmy is here between building
spaceships always one more question on
his stupid
lips the resident American daddy of
citrek Gandalf deito is always on
Deck our Tech wizard Matt is here too he
doesn't watch movies unless they are
blue everyone tells him short tall thin
fat even Brad Wright said shut up
Matt Jay's here too hoping he won't need
a we praying this live will be but plug
free spilling the beans Amazon doesn't
want you to
know ah I need a wheel already I better
go Merry Christmas Sid
trekers
King he's back of course stormy went why
wouldn't stormy wander
off um got another quick little thing to
do and then I I have something to say
for one second one second Merry
Christmas Sid trackers from La 2023
can't wait to
talk have amazing
holid and you saw what she was watching
back there it was great love Jen that's
our Jenny Sten really close friend of
the channel and just amazing she's she's
promise she'll be back in the new year
to talk all stuff I just wanted to
quickly thank other people that appeared
on the channel uh like Mike from the
solo one podcast Melvin from sci-fi
quest mark from the shuttle pod show all
the guys from the companion even Aaron
that came on a few times and we loved
him as well and MC from the forever um
Adventure Network even though he argues
with me a lot um
Jim who the hell is
Jim I'm oh my God oh my God I'm gonna
send that to him oh yeah Jim and Jim
that came on your mate you mentioned him
last week I forgot about him he was nice
I like Jim um so and Jim that came
on yeah just go message him for me and
tell him I forgot he existed um I will
I'll send him this
video right now 's not here to be
honest and I did one of very quickly say
that that all three of you guys you're
just absolute Legends thank you so much
I don't I don't I try to express my
sorry he's J that know
so um he's dead to me anyway um but no
you guys don't have to come on and do
these videos every week and you do
anyway and it can't be because you like
it so there must be some other reason so
um just just because you pay me £10,000
a month obviously well I've got to spend
those big YouTube money somewhere it's
only 10,000 I'm getting 7500 yeah don't
tell oh I quit yeah we've muted him for
a reason um he he just gets um but
plugs uh one a
month just one I thought he had him for
each day well does he know he's he's
muted I figing it out right
now
[Music]